What do you think?
It's great
Do you think it's an issue that I'm on parole?
Sorry?
I just made a stupid joke about
being on parole
So you're a writer?
Yes
I'm assuming this is a work in progress?
I'm trying
Are you... breaking up with me?
(Phone rings)
Hey what's up?
Ben lives here
What?
Hey
So we're neighbors?
Hi...hi
That's weird. That's kind of like a crazy ex-girlfriend thing to do
Excuse me?
I mean I didn't know that he lived there
Oooowww
Oh my god, are you okay?
I'm fine
We're gonna get into a cab
Where'd the blood come from?
So how are you?
Its going pretty well
I'm...I'm on the road
Wait you're touring?
I'm sorry I meant the figurative road, I see how that would be misleading
Are you guys dating?
Yeah
Cool. Great.
Do you think you could back off Ben a little bit?
But I... live here
Yeah, I can see you when you're creeping outside his window
Definitely not creeping
Why is it a crime to want to be friends with your ex-boyfriend?
What's going on with Ben?
Um.
Nothing
He's probably still in love with you
He's almost certainly still in love with you
You ready? Yes, born ready
I don't know what I'm doing
Want to go get drunk? Yes
I thought that if I ended it, that it would be less painful later on
But it wasn't
I think about you all the time